zu dem thema ja dass das hat tatsächlich
sich gewandelt als ich dann einmal
posten ist ja sehr vorsichtig da muss
man sehr vorsichtig sein auch mit kritik
als er gesagt hat also das beste der
besten schutz ist drei mal geimpft und
eben entsprechend gepostet und dann noch
mal dreifach infiziert wirklich schwer
und dann ist man relativ geschützt für
mehrere jahre das waren seine worte und
da habe ich angefangen nachzudenken ich
war aber am wochenende in österreich und
über nacht ist unser nachbar ein neues
land geworden ohne masken pflicht
nämlich nirgendwo noch im einzelhandel
die menschen sind fröhlich einander
zugewandt und auch mit der impfpflicht
haben die österreicher stolz gemacht
entgegen früherer vorhaben weil die
politiker in wien nämlich gemerkt haben
verstanden haben dass der pieks zur
prävention nicht mehr allgemein
durchsetzbar ist das eine impfpflicht
auch nicht durchzusetzen ist bei uns an
zwar unsere ampelkoalition ihre doch
diesen mut das einzugestehen hat
eigentlich nur mister klartext im
bundestag neben kein bosbach hier eben
wolfgang kubicki der rest von kubicas
kollegen versucht zu verschleppen was
gar nicht mehr zu retten ist nämlich die
impfpflicht am donnerstag soll es da die
erste beratung geben im bundestag und
einer impfpflicht die auch nach meiner
festen überzeugung nicht mehr kommen
würden denn die grundannahme für die
impfpflicht werden darüber gesprochen
wie stimmt nämlich nicht mehr dass eine
impfung schützt vor einer infektion
geschützt mich das glaube ich bei einem
schweren verlauf aber nicht vor einer
infektion dh eine impfpflicht kann nur
kommen wenn sie wirklich schützt das tut
sie nicht ich finde die politiker
sollten den mut haben endlich
abzuschwören donnerstag ist dafür ein
guter
da lassen wir doch direkt sie darauf
antworten herr doktor brandenburg jaja
an der trifft den nagel auf den kopf ich
sehe mich einen ganz neuen funktionen
dass ich an dem regierungssprecher zu
bestimmen muss das ist genauso ihren
heiligen regierungssprecher das wirklich
jemals ablegt aber ja er kann nur
zustimmen also die frage ist aber und
das ist der kernpunkt glaube ich macht
euch ehrlich und da liegt das problem
diese regierungen auch die
vorgängerregierung haben ja mit dieser
dieser serie von lügen mit diesen harten
eingriffen in das die gesundheit in das
leben der bürger so viel vertrauen
verspielt ein wolfgang bosbach setzt
hier und sind es auf den punkt und sagt
na aber ich habe das doch getan ich habe
mich behandeln lassen ich habe dieses
risiko in kauf genommen was ist denn
jetzt mit mir ich bin schwer getäuscht
worden und dieses vertrauen was da
zerstört wurde das ist unser
eigentliches problem wir sehen welche
spaltungen es in der gesellschaft
gebracht hat wir sehen einen wirklich
aus meiner sicht nie dagewesenen
vertrauensverlust in die regierung wir
haben berufsmäßige lügner und
hochstapler in vielfachen funktion
erlebt dass eine frau baerbock ist die
wieder ihr lebenslauf
zusammengeschustert und jetzt kommt so
etwas auch noch ein eingriff eingriff
ins leben ich fürchte es reicht nicht
einfach nur damit dass man jetzt sagt es
tut uns leid nicht wir haben das
gewaltverbrechen versucht jetzt lassen
wir es sein und gehen einen schritt
zurück es brauchte einen neuaufbau an
vertrauen und ich zweifel daran dass das
einfach durch ein unterlassen dieser
impfpflicht jetzt geschieht ich glaube
auch wie hier anders es wird nicht zu
dieser impfpflicht kommen ich glaube
aber es wird in diesen mechanismus
danach zu ähnlichen versuchen in zukunft
kommen und das müssen wir ausschließen
wir brauchen eine aufarbeitung dieser
vorgänge ich glaube das war jetzt kein
werbeblock für die ampel wenn man uns
das angucken hat die ampel aber auch für
die impfpflicht weder für die generelle
noch für die einrichtungs bezogene die
ist nun durch weil man tatkraft
signalisieren wollte aber für die für
die allgemeine impfpflicht gar keine
mehrheit das ist schon interessant weder
in der fdp noch bei den grünen auch in
der spd gibt es keine eigene mehrheit
und das wird so eine art
parlamentarische ist lotto was sie haben
donnerstag sehen das heißt man wird
verschiedene entwürfe endlich mit 18 im
krieg ab 50 durch stimmen und dann wird
mal gucken ob sich nach dem durchfallen
des ersten genügend leute dann auf das
kleinere übel den nächsten finden wenn
das nicht der fall ist fällt am ende
alles durch und auch der vorschlag der
union der ist ja aus meiner sicht noch
ein bisschen der rest plausibelste wenn
man einen vorratsbeschluss wenn es mal
so kommen sollte dann könnten wir eine
impfpflicht anschalten das problem ist
man müsste man schlägt beschließt oder
eine leere hülle also wenn es eine
krankheits lage gibt und dann gibt es
auch noch einen impfstoff wohl eine
impfpflicht wichtig wäre dann könnten
wir sie zur pflicht machen ja gut das
kann der bundestag aber jederzeit es
kann jederzeit eine sondersitzung
einberufen werden eigentlich ist das 1 1
aus flucht angebot an die ampel die
keine eigene mehrheit hat und der
impfgegner kubicki hat mehrere stapel
von autogrammkarten auf seinem
schreibtisch liegen die pro woche
verschickt einfach weil die leute das
richtig toll finden ein beispiel der
impfgegner kubicki hat dann doch dafür
gestimmt nicht mit fraktions rationale
und der disziplin die die einrichtung ja
aber ich fürchte auch damit hat er seine
glaubwürdigkeit verspielt bei denjenigen
die sagen er hätte es mal ernsthafte
gegenwehr geben das ist aber viel
überzeugungen in politik das ist jetzt
aber dass da sagen sie wieder als macht
pragmatiker das will ich ihn nicht
nachsehen aber ich denke dass das
vertrauen bei den bürgern nur dann
wieder hergestellt werden kann wenn
diese verhaltensmuster mal durchbrochen
wir haben den menschen das gibt auch
erkenntnisse in der politik muss man ja
auch sehen es gab situationen wo auch
wirklich breite teile der bevölkerung
höchst besorgt gewesen sind und auch
jetzt sind ja noch viele der ansicht
egal hauptsache wir tun irgendwas da
draußen ist eine große reform denn warum
denn das ist doch gerade die frage ist
doch alles an mit einer bundeskanzlerin
merkel die beim aufkommen dieses virus
sofort eine million ihrer seltenen
fernseh auftritte hingelegt hat und
sofort den menschen versprach wir werden
wirklich alles tun jedes geld ausgeben
um jeden toten ja immerhin sei es war
nicht so weit ist das war sehr schnell
und die menschen haben systematisch
angst gemacht bekommen das war ja also
ich dass das spiel der politik und jetzt
klammern sie sich sogar an masken im
freien nicht wir erleben jetzt wie ein
bundesland nach dem anderen ankündigt
wir halten die maske 1000 ist geschlagen
es ist ein wunderbares gefühl beim ki ka
am anfang ich dachte immer wo ich jetzt
meine maus gewicht mal vom tisch
aufstand und so und man hat es ganz
verlangt aber es macht die menschen
wirklich freier und an besser
miteinander wenn da ein sachen zu den
impfungen sagen die politik hat auch nie
so kommuniziert dass sie gesagt hat wir
haben uns auch mal geirrt was ist uns
den vermittelt wird eine im modul reicht
zwei impfungen sind besser dann kam auf
einmal
der booster der unbedingt sein wer aber
am anfang nie vermittelt worden ist wenn
mir gesagt worden es mit 2 mit zwei
impfungen bist du dein leben lang
geschützt da darf sich keiner
hingestellt und gesagt wir haben uns
geirrt du brauchst noch den booster bis
hin zu ich wiederhole mich an drosten
drei impfungen booster drei mal
infiziert dann wahrscheinlich auf
mehrere jahre gut geschützt wenn die
infektion möglichst schwer war wir sind
all gestartet von einer impfung
beziehungsweise zwei impfungen sind da
jetzt angekommen aber irgendwo entlang
des weges hat mich ja irgend jemanden
gehört gesagt hat okay waren das früher
anders gesagt haben sich aber neue
erkenntnisse gegeben und das ist auch
ein großer großer vertrauensverluste
sich dadurch eben minuten manifestiert
in solchen eben anders es ist der in der
medizin banal als arzt kennt man das
nicht ein patient will seinem arzt
vertrauen so will ja auch die
bevölkerung ganz allgemein dass die
regierung sie schützt wenn ich als arzt
einen offenkundigen fehler mache und
mein patient spürt das ja der merkt er
lief etwas mehr
meistens spielt das doch so schlimm sind
die fehler medizin meist nicht jeder
student lernt gibt diesen fehler zu geht
zum patienten gesteht das räumen dass
ein in der realität lernst du dann
schnell vor sich die versicherung legt
der hersteller du kannst nicht einfach
ein fehler aber wir brauchen wieder der
politik